you've got to take a shot you have to
live at the edge of your capabilities
you got to live where you're almost
certain you're gonna fail failure is
only really failure if it's final
failure is only really failure if you
don't learn anything from it we've all
failed at things I'm gonna continue to
fail at stuff right it's the most
powerful tool you can use
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it
and make a difference using it so let's
start your day off right grab your cup
of coffee and sip on today's message
fail forward over to you will Smith I
[Music]
love this one fail early fail often fail
forward you know it's always a little
bit frustrating to me when people have a
negative relationship with failure
failure is a massive part of being able
to be successful you have to get
comfortable with failure yet you have to
actually seek failure failure is where
all of the lessons are you know when you
go to the gym and you work out you're
actually seeking failure you want to
take your muscles to the point where you
get to failure because that's where the
the adaptation is that's where growth is
successful people who fail a lot they
fail a whole lot more than they succeed
but they extract the lessons from the
failure and they used
the the energy and they use the wisdom
to come around to the next phase of
success you got to take a shot you have
to live at the edge of your capabilities
you got to live where you're almost
certain you're gonna fail that's the
reason for a practice practice is
controlled failure you're getting to
your limit getting to your limit getting
to your limit you can't lift that you
can't do that you until you get to the
point that all of a sudden your body
makes the adjustment and then you can do
it
failure actually helps you to recognize
the areas where you need to evolve so
fail early fail often fail forward I
think most people have an unhealthy
relationship with failure I think I
think people see failure is this really
bad thing and I think most people are
afraid of failing in front of other
people that's the ultimate judgment they
don't want to be seen as somebody who is
a failure where failure is only really
failure if it's final failure is only
really failure if you don't learn
anything from it all failure is is a way
to know that this thing that you try
didn't work that's that's great learning
right if you're never failing it means
you're playing life so safe that you've
never taken a risk and that's that's
where most people live most people hate
their life they hate their job their
waking up and drive into something that
they hate every day that's where most
people are living and because they're so
afraid of failing on something else that
they want to scale back and play life so
safe that they're gonna live the rest of
their life in misery that's where most
people are living and if you look at the
people who are successful any of your
heroes any of your idols speakers
authors musicians actors entrepreneurs
whoever athletes they failed a lot
Bailey's is part of the process the
people who win the most fail the most
because they failed a lot a lot of the
videos in this series didn't work you
know the top ten series you know that
meant to me series you know the ant
spresso series there's a lot that you
don't know because we tried it three
times and it didn't work so I killed it
I moved on to something else that we
have more failed series on this channel
than winners we have more failed series
in this channel than most people ever
even tried period and so you don't want
to say I love failures failures is great
but in a sense it's kind of it's kind of
true like if you learn to take the
lesson from the failure to then make it
better the next time you will win
because otherwise again you're you're
playing your life so safe that you never
take a risk and you never shoot for what
you want or you have lots of skill you
could be great at something but you're
you're doing the race against
three-year-olds you win every race
because it's a guaranteed Xuan thing and
you're not gonna be happy with it so I
came back from an event in Palm Springs
a YouTube event and I was pushing a lot
of people to do better to be better to
drive harder to believe in their talent
more to not settle for what they're
doing right now
and one guy who I didn't know very well
I pushed too far and he got upset and
then I had to spend the evening
rewinding and unpacking it showing the
love not just the push but showing the
love and I ended up having to go to
dinner and do a couple of other things
which I didn't really want to go to this
I wanted to make videos I wanted to
create more content but I didn't want to
leave it on the negative and I was asked
about it afterwards and say listen I'm
it's awesome it's great knowing you
where your limits are is great if I had
pushed everybody and everybody just said
wow that's true that's great you're
right and then gone off and done stuff
that's not actually a win because maybe
I could have pushed them harder because
maybe we could have made even more
progress together while I had that time
knowing what my limits are tells me
where I need to focus
tells me that I'm doing the right thing
and so it's just a perspective shift
that one failure was actually the best
part because now I know how to do it
better next time now I know I can
dissect and say okay I made some
mistakes here next time will be better
and that's what failure does for people
that's what failure does for people who
end up winning where if you see failures
I sock your personal failure is not a
reflection of who you are as human being
so because my top ten series did well
now I'm a great person and because these
20 or other series that we tried didn't
do well now I'm my worthless human being
that's how people interpret it just
because a project or an idea of yours
didn't work out it's not a personal
reflection of you of how good or bad
yours a human being and so just learning
to embrace failure know that as part of
the process expect it massive ongoing
forever as long as you're continue to
push them
up and grow you will fail forever and
ever and ever and it's amazing and it's
part of the process great that's the
mindset of the people who win and I hope
you guys can adjust it today too because
I want you to win badly now I've got a
special bonus clip I think you're gonna
enjoy a round failure but first question
today I want to know what is the biggest
failure that you've ever made what is
the biggest failure that you've ever
made let's release it here share it
together put in the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
we're try so hard in our lives to fit in
we try to fit into certain groups
certain frats certain sororities you
know among certain friends yet the
people we idolize our most are the ones
that stand out but when you're prepared
there is no fear there is no fear of
failure okay because even if you've
walked out of something and you feel
like you've failed at it your
preparation is so strong that you're
gonna take that failure and turn it into
the outcome you desire and most people
stop at failure okay we've all failed at
things I'm gonna continue to fail at
stuff right it's the most powerful tool
you can use but it all depends on how
you use it you know we talk about it in
relentless okay a scalpel okay in the
hands of an individual it can do
unbelievable damage in the hands of a
professional of a doctor it saves lives
so it's the same thing with failure it's
how you use it it's that drive inside of
you okay it's what we talk about the
dark side the dark side is filled with
failure but it's the fuel that burns you
like something that's never burned
inside you before I think if you don't
fail you're not doing it right
to be honest I think you should be
failing often but it's important it
teaches you it limits and shows you like
the limits you need to pass nobody ever
made mistakes Mike would be really
boring it's true yeah if you only try to
succeed then you're limiting yourself
not to fail which your failure could
eventually believe the greatest
underside yeah never be afraid of not
getting it right
or not getting the part or not getting
the job like it's just one more notch in
your belt but you're still gonna wear it
that the long piece of leather there's
tons of room for more notches nobody
sees the like 17 plus years of work that
I've done before today where you finally
stumbled upon a video of mine during a
research experiment a shark was placed
into a large tank of water and then some
small fish were released into that tank
and you would expect the shot quickly
swam around the tank what's the fish and
then ended up eating all of them then a
strong piece of fiberglass was inserted
into the tank this would create a
division between where the shark started
and where the smaller fish started again
the shop quickly attacked but this time
the shark went in straight into the
fiberglass divider and bounced off it
tried this several times again and again
and again until it became tired and
weakened meanwhile the fish on the other
side of the divider carried on swimming
peacefully after about an hour the shark
finally gave up this experiment was
repeated several dozen times over the
next few weeks where the shark became
less aggressive every single time it got
to the point where the shark
stopped trying to attack and eat the
fish at all the fiberglass was then
removed out of the tank and to their
amazement the shark still did not attack
the shark had been trained through habit
that a fiberglass divider was there and
that he would bounce off and therefore
didn't even consider it at the same time
the small fish freely swung
the moral of the story many of us are
experiencing setbacks and failures in
everyday life eventually we get
emotionally drained tired unmotivated
and we stop trying like the shark in the
story we believe that because we've been
unsuccessful in the past that that
barrier still exists even for new
ventures in other words we continue to
see a barrier in our heads that
separates us from our dreams even though
there is no real barrier between where
we are and where we want to go and
remember this the teacher has failed
more times than the student is even if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe you act like I have a tussle
what a wail out of a handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access